Freddy filmmaker who's never shot an
action sequence what would you tell them
I had more than one camera that would be
the first biggest advice the second
advice is choreograph choreograph
choreograph when you're doing an action
sequence storyboard everything first so
if you don't believe in storyboarding
when it comes to action storyboarded so
you know exactly what your key players
are going to be then get your stunt guys
and and keep going through it because
it's interesting like when you practice
with the stunt people when the talent
starts practicing and for me like being
the actor and producer it was kind of
cool because since as the actor I'm able
you're able to practice with the stunt
guys and then you start to come up with
stuff on your own and then your director
or your producer is going to take that
input so when you're doing action action
requires the most pre-production of
anything a lot of people will say like
oh well we'll wait till we get to the
actual location and we'll see how it
looks or this is how I want to do it and
and they've storyboarded storyboarded it
but they haven't gone through the actual
physicality of it because with action
you you got to go through it especially
especially for low budget films because
for low budget in defense independent
films our action isn't going to be like
cars racing through streets it's not
going to be like guys jumping from
building to building it's going to be
guys or gals punching each other that's
the bottom line punching each other
going through windows landing on
concrete a lot of the times with small
independent films you don't have the
proper safety gear and both my films we
didn't be shot in foreign countries and
you know it's dangerous and you got to
practice practice practice and that's
the key so if you're doing action
choreograph everything take the time and
hire people that will will work with you
in pre-production and then come back for
the film
and could be the same the same guys it's
like a dance partner you know you you
dance with someone and you learned their
moves and then you don't dance with them
for six months then you come back to a
ball and you pick up right where you
started you know so that's how you want
your your scenes to be and and it'll go
a lot quicker there's not going to be
like oh you know you're you're too far
from the camera or you're too close to
the punch there's also a comfort level
that takes place between the talent
where the other one guy knows he's not
going to kick the other guy in the head
you know so that that comfort happens as
well I understand on from what I hear on
on big studio films like you know studio
films it's it's a little different
because you've got big talent and you
know you've got real stuntman who if the
talent kicks ass up man in the head he's
going to take he's getting paid for it
but on low budget you have to
choreograph and you have to practice
practice
you